hello citizens of Auto Dale and welcome
to tonight's PSA
what is a model citizen well you're not
gonna use your mic again
how was work today honey it was a
delight well families of Auto Dale
a model citizen is a providing father a
mortal citizen is a caring mother all in
service of a scrappy young boy or girl a
model child raised by a model family to
become a model citizen of their own
[Music]
for autodale is hardly automatic you and
your families are the gears that keep
our engines turning and turning and let
us open this perfect cycle never ends
daily check how are we doing tonight
well work was a delight well dinner was
just wonderful and Junior's just been
tucked in Splendid taking after his
father I'd hope seems everything's in
order
leaving so soon one care to join my
lovely lady for a dance with you John
one day Mrs Robinson who
you disappointed the lady Joe deepest
apologist Robinson family but duty calls
it would seem the cycle never ends
I wonder what this is getting at
let's just watch it what do you think
about police robots and [ __ ] tell me
what I need to tell me some something
you know about police robots I mean
apparently like San Francisco just made
it legal first like robots to have
lethal Force I doubt that that's what it
said and I I saw that and I was like San
Francisco doesn't even prosecute doesn't
even give their their human police
that's what I was saying
that didn't sound right with me when I
saw that yeah plan put on hold killer
police robots planned put on hold like
the way these articles are written is
just for clicks it has yeah I mean okay
let's look at the CNN Headline a
mid-public outcry San Francisco
officials reverse course and reject
Police use of robots to kill so who
knows what the real policy is maybe
they're just saying they will send
robots into situations that they know an
officer might be killed in or like a
extreme situation yeah there's like a
bomb or some [ __ ] and yeah exactly and
that robot then can maybe you know take
out a bad guy a hostage or something you
know a hostage holder but you know they
make it seem like oh they're gonna send
the robots to just start killing all the
black people because that's what it's
about because that's what the
anti-police thing is about okay let's go
and then rap on Instagram post a picture
about it and [ __ ] knock the country
burns down
it's the dumbest page
[Music]
okay so this is saying uh when your
mortal child is grown up and is ready to
start a model family of Their Own
a True Modern citizen
that their duties are finished and their
courses run
[Music]
Lewis kind of hoping that the psycho
would never end
[Music]
what now they they just started doing
lines and growing at strip clubs
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
model citizens
thank you
I'm just not deep enough deepest
apologies
the duty calls
afraid email is hardly automatically
[Music]
and your families are what keep our
engines turning and turning let us open
this perfect cycle never ends
I think the reason the kid doesn't have
the mask on is because like kids are
still born with their creativity and
then they're kind of just placed like
Society forms them into like the Matrix
this model citizen okay let's go
foreign
there's nothing wrong with being a model
citizen either you know that's just it
like people who say like the one comment
about be who you are be who you are
that's great but maybe that's what
somebody is and what they want like let
them do their thing too don't [ __ ] on
people just because they want the Square
life that is okay too and I don't know
so what whatever I know am I missing
this like is this just beyond me am I
being some shallow Dopey I don't know I
think it's just like like I said you've
seen the clip of Kanye West and he's
like when you're a little kid and they
tell you not to not to go on the coffee
tables by the time you're 40 years so
you've got a wall full of coffee tables
calculating you into traffic okay and
you know as long as like when you're
little like you feel like you can like
own the world and you do all this stuff
and you go on top of a coffee table and
that table means nothing to you but then
to the adults it's like don't stand on
that and then by the time you're older
you have like a whole wall of coffee
tables of [ __ ] that you just can't do
because other people have told you and
just form the way you think I think
that's kind of what that is it's like in
the ideal Society they would just have
ultimate control over people like they
get your their use out of you and even
though like that's why you don't have
the mask on when you're young because
you still have like that that youth and
innocence and as it forms you more you
start putting your mask on the robot do
you want to dance with my wife all right
maybe I'm just overthinking it all right
maybe I'm under thinking it but the
coffee I'm gonna use your coffee table
analogy the coffee table analogy is so
that you don't go out into the world
running around acting like an [ __ ]
there's a balance that I think you can
strike we can strike as a society where
remember I remember when you were a
little kid and we lived in the North End
and we were always every five minutes in
a bakery and you'd like you and all your
friends would go to the bakery glass and
be like like that one and I would you
were taught from a very young age don't
touch the glass because then somebody
has to clean that that's it I don't give
a [ __ ] about your kid experience of
being able to touch the glass some that
old lady from behind the counter every
time you leave she's got to come out
with a Windex and wipe that down that
was about courtesy that's the coffee
table analogy right there it's about
courtesy and manners and there's nothing
wrong with that because now I know but
it's an announcement we go through
Society without stomping on each other
and being courteous now finding some
balance and also letting that child find
ways to let that expressive energy out
and be themselves and Blossom into
whatever God wanted them to blossom into
or they want to blossom into or whatever
the thing is that's that that's what
matters but let's not pretend that any
sort of order is completely out of order
okay Dairy to stand on coffee table in
my house [ __ ] dare you
[Music]
[Music]